I did. This is session ten with a spender and Karen and Craig. And we're just about to begin the session.
And if identification.
We ended last session with you talking about your lovely house
and time at French's forest all the years you spent there and maybe you want to start there. All all somewhere else.
I want to go back from the forest house. In actual fact after we moved to French's forest.
It was half a time when accommodation for still so awfully awfully. To get anywhere.
And we had a free the author John Clarke who was very anxious to live to find a place to live in.
So we let her into the flat we had me and told her to pay the Internet.
Well this worked for a while but then let you stay on it anyhow.
Well I wanted to leave the house of the forest and go back to the flattered North Sydney. When I returned from Europe.
This person per woman from. And so me. And she said. Well we've got to get something.
And we don't for any of those churches you know who are really those trade unions
or Liberal party communist party party we've got to keep them all out. But it will be a fellowship of black and white.
Well. Nothing in actual fact. And.
For two years because Pearl vanished again and went back to the bush and I was involved in many other things
when she appeared. And she called at seven o'clock one morning. And wondered what ever had happened.
I mean you just didn't go visiting people in Riyadh heard seven o'clock in the morning.
But here in Pillow hit it off beautifully
and she said with him in a little kitchen it while he had these conflicts before he went off to work
and then she said to me put the building on. And we said Hey just some tea and she said we've got to.
And this is how I wanted to play and one of the goals of the organization would be to abolish the Aboriginal welfare.
Now she was in fact a member of that board and if it were anyone else black or white they would want to continue.
But she was a woman who thought a better. Other people.
So I said well you know I was awfully reluctant to tell you the truth.
I couldn't see why I would have to be involved in the rights of anyone else other than the rights of all Australians
all the people of the world and it was at a time
when the African Americans were having a great struggle for their rights
and the people in the African states were fighting for independence and I sort of felt well you know around the world.
Why should I get involved in a local thing. It's the people of the world who need their rights.
Well who is Arcade ing
and he said I was being told that I could play a part on the international stage for human rights. Well you know.
Little me so. Pearl was very very persistent. And she came. That morning and she went away.
And I didn't even think about it then she came a few mornings later to settle the tea
and in the meantime she'd had some words with the street and a woman by the name of Rosie in good. A remarkable woman.
One of the very early female graduate graduates of Sydney University
and I think she graduated in May have been social work
but I have an idea it had to do with literature I'm not quite sure about that but anyhow.
We think it's time that a good organisation should be formed it was given a lot of encouragement from these two women
and they'd she came back to me and it was Jessie who said to her you must get Fife you simply must get by
and pokémon told me this.
Now I had two very very good friends which I think I've mentioned earlier or perhaps I haven't by the name of March.
Both poets Muir of considerable size as the poet
and they were very good to me that helped me in fact with accommodation at one stage
and I talked to who was a public servant. I had in his capacity.
In the capacity of his work had to visit country towns from time to time. And he became very concerned about the.
Situation of the people because what he observed now.
I talked to me you are about things that poor Pearl had been suggesting to me.
And he was so enthusiastic just stick he came from quite a comfortable background.
He was a political person he thought about things that were political that he was also a gentle loving
and compassionate person beautiful powered anyhow that he will live in that boat house incurably in Kerry bill of St
Kira Billy and it was a huge house great old rambling house
and I said Miller said Our place is available if you want to have a meeting and I just told him I had been pushed back.
And said the meeting was cool in house. And I just ask was that managed by SEE THE POET. Marge price or the poet.
Yes that's right. And she used her maiden name parser after. He died at the age of thirty.
But we got down there into this lovely old house
and I always recall the first meeting was right in one of her books the book.
And she had Helen Thomas they were in the kitchen because Helen was checking the proofs with Madge.
But the rest of us got into the arms through and at that meeting the pearl. My sister massing. Grace badly.
Rose in Ghouta MN and her sister a person an architect by the name of John Walker.
And I think that was it that may have been a couple more. I think about that later.
And so I have the minutes of that meeting in Mirror's handwriting.
I had a copy made recently to a court and I thought it likely. Anyhow.
The meeting got on to what he and it was agreed that we would form an organization and to work for the limitation of.
Legislation that discriminated against the Aboriginal people of New South Wales.
Always remember saying and that will include abolishing the boat the Aboriginal welfare of. Well we had a cup of tea.
We all came and went home happy that an organization formed and this was the evolution of fellowship.
Well at that stage it didn't have an as yet so. There was a woman by the name of Lucy woodcock.
She was the president of the Teachers Federation. And also I think President of one of the street.
Organizations for feminism. The United Association of Women.
Lucy lived in George Street where the Regent Hotel is now she was on the first floor there. Huge flat. Lovely.
Big rooms and you'd look down onto the key. Well at that stage I guess she was in her sixty's.
She was a woman who knew how to conduct a meeting and. And she would rule with him and Rod anyhow.
Pearl went to see now Pearl knew a lot of these old famous.
Because Purnell been around Sydney coming
and going for a long time she knew what feminism horse about on one occasion she said to me.
My sister Kathy said Oh I'm not going to vote tomorrow. The elections were on and people said you go and vote.
Some women went to jail. So that you would have that right.
So Perl you lose a pill knew Lucy very well and Lucy offered who fly out for a meeting for the fellowship.
Because Lucy said look if you could look at the station have to give it a name.
So we all got into Lucy's flat now by this time the apparatus people had come good.
I was working on her lap or is people who is working on the rate for people to get them to come to the meeting.
Well Paul didn't have as much of success as I did because there is a lot of people who are very forward thinking people
and some of the cruises care. That was say or any of people they have now and. The stewards. And truly long bottom.
Marian Jackson.
Magnificent painful wonderful people so they came to Lucy's flat and from Redfern a bloke by the name of Ted
and came Ted was one of the very few days who worked in industries and he was a train. I try I am driver In fact I.
I should look him off and I believe he's still living. Now.
And people actually only able to muster three people from Redfern.
And she was a bit ashamed of it she says you can get more of those black.
Anyhow said Lucy Sara chair this meeting most undemocratic I say so. She said all that place all that.
And there was silence and she said well the first things we have to do is get someone to take the minutes. Now I.
Cajoled a friend of mine by the name of Irene Michael. She had an office in Sydney and she ran a typing business and.
A name was Freeman. She had escaped. And that was a price on fact because she was very active duty.
And she came when I asked her to. Because she said one of the first question she asked when she came to Sydney.
But we must try again and it was a bit of a mystery to that none were to be seen.
So when I told her we were involved in it. She said. All right. Face How come.
Funny woman in a way but she came along and she was a very good shorthand typist
and so we said Well aren't you take the minute she said. All right.
But you people remember this is my living and I'm doing going to do this for nothing. Yes we said well thank you Ira.
In fact you do. If we hadn't a cracker of course needless to say.
Now the extraordinary thing about it was that it seemed the Aboriginal people were waiting for this to happen.
Just waiting for it to happen because Pearl had said to them which what if any church.
And we don't want any political parties. And that nobody's going to dominate this organization.
Well that thought this was code they didn't want to be told what to do. They wanted to make the decision.
That was very clear to me. Carol very early.
Well one of the first things on the agenda was that we should fund the organization
and this is fresh in my memory it all happened yesterday.
Someone said let's call it he said Oh I have been thinking about this and I thought we should include the words.
And it went on to speak about the founder of the.
Fellowship of Australian writers and have fellowship brought people together and we want to bring the black
and white people together and let's call it fellowship. Well it was agreement that that word could be.
And then we all went on and. I would suggest that we call it the Aboriginal Australian. And the tram driver said.
Don't use that word. And Lucy. Which word use if you're referring to. He said that word. She said He said her.
Strongly and he said the other one. He said what we'll get he said is some callers. We've had enough of that.
That the people from lapper are said.
And what's wrong with that you know put up a battle and said Ted saw the light and accepted it.
And it's my opinion that that organization. To think.
And have a title that I think Lou that there were good Aboriginal gave contributed to the dignity of the hip ritual
people of New South Wales. More and more people began to come out and say you know. I found that meeting.
Very moving because I had never in fact fully realised what it was like to be an Aboriginal person.
And it made me feel I valued my. My freedom. That no one could come. And to our house and take me away.
That wasn't quite as much as no one could come and say you can't.
Or you're not entitled to it or you can't come to this school is a special school for you. You can only live there.
That is area that the gap and said you could Lizzie. And if you want to go across the border.
You have to come and get permission from us all of these things and the people set around and talked about the.
Restrictions on their lives and per the fact that the organization that was carrying out
and supervising these restrictions was the Habersham welfare. And if we didn't do nothing. We had to get rid of that.
And let the people the people the rules and laws of the state government.
Now issues a very politically advanced woman talking. And she had many years of experience behind her like me.
In her own people. So for us. The main meeting didn't end until we agreed that we'd have a function to raise money.
For the kitty.
And Irene kept saying look I've got an office and you can use Martellus and providing you pay the bill for your call.
And she is now I say you know but she held us together in a way.
And said and you can come in and out of the office whenever you want to. You can come after five o'clock.
And the office was you know wonderful situation writing to mention and very nice
and it filled with sunshine during the winter. And that was very nice.
And we're grateful we behave ourselves and we didn't abuse her office and was overjoyed and saluted.
She was brewing with excitement. So after it was all open Lucy made a cup of tea which cetera.
And I had taken a big packet of Arnott's biscuits and biscuits and a cup of tea.
And we thought we'd done well for the evening. And they left it to me to find out how we could find F.
Where we could have a public. To raise some money. Well I had one time the friendship of my landlady of mine.
And her husband had just completed a huge house.
For the family at Golden on the no sure he'd built it out of the local pinks he was a stonemason.
And she said Oh my house is there I went and saw her and said simple.
We have to raise some money for the fellowship and she says oh I want to be in the Phillips ship
and you could help us and we can have.
A musical leave me because she was a friend of poverty
and Paul Williams You can have a musical evening at our house the piano too.
And we don't have to have a bag and we'll take up a collection. And it was.
So the evening was organized with Paul coming along and a singer by then I have Mary McClintock.
And Mary was a student of Paul Williams. And I had become friendly with an Aboriginal person who was on a scholarship.
To have her voice trained and she'd come to Sydney looking for a teacher and I took her to a pool.
She was a very advanced sing about the name of Nancy. ALICE.
And as Paul said at first her voice was all over the place but he soon got it together and it was held very.
Tightly and she had a magnificent control. She was very advanced musically. She came along.
She didn't sing that evening she just sat there because she wanted to support the fellowship.
And then later she said Well I'll give her a cycle to raise some funds
and that came later they were wonderful evenings
and we had the music of the very base for the fellowship nothing less with Paul and Bob But you know forefront.
So we raised over two hundred pounds which was quite considerable. Then we said we had to that's right.
We raised this money and we had the money in the kitty which was held by.
I think Irene activists are in great treasure and she knew how to be careful believe you me.
For a little while until we got a treasure but then we said we had to have a public meeting.
So that we could at least more people to support us so we sent invitations out to the unions
and the churches who wouldn't have a thing to mention. Jesse.
She would arrange that we could have the United Association of Women. Free afraid.
That she and Lucy were involved that they said we could.
So we got invitations asked for people to come to a public meeting. And the meeting was held in the place was packed.
And schoolteachers came at him. And I just ask you where that was where the meeting was held.
So the meeting was held there in the room so that you know it. Association who women sixty one Market Street Sydney.
Very well known to the famous.
And so we called we only had a sort of temporary executive to say there was president he was president
and secretary treasurer.
So the main thing was open to elect an executive and people nominated and among the nominees was Pearl
and a great Aboriginal leader who was very involved with that social reform. William Ferguson.
And it was a nominated and there was ten people still lean towards my.
Presidents of organisations women could be secretaries and get on with the work.
The election for president and the day after that which it was for quite some years. She had initiated the groundwork.
And I wouldn't electors prison. And vanished. But we got the organization go in and we kept it.
So I could understand why people warned us against political parties wanting to take it over
and so forth because there was a strong move by the Labor Party members of the Labor Party to move
and dominate there was a strong move by member of the Liberal Party to do the same thing.
To say nothing of the Communist Party over there in a big.
And this went on that we were the whole time we were able to keep it fairly straight these people did it
and I were always very vocal. And I'm sure that during the call it was considered. A raid organization.
But it was it was not. Now short while after a couple of years. That was in nineteen fifty six.
Well it was in nineteen fifty seven. That Jesse one called me in to town to meet her on the Saturday afternoon.
And I went into town and we met.
The that was the lawyer for the fellowship an honorary I might mention bad the name of Christian jolly Smith one of the
if. Women to graduate but certainly the first woman to establish her own legal company in Sydney.
And she looked after us kept us out of jail half the time because we were prepared to gamble
and do all kinds of things to raise money. Anyhow. And she helped. The constitution. But. Yes that's right.
So yes he called me and he was a very good friend of the Christian church. And we met in Christian's office afternoon.
And yes he had also called.
As president of the fellowship
and the four of us now Jesse previously had been talking to me about the need for a federal body. And the need.
Very leary mentions I think a better referendum but he went over my continent. And that afternoon she came in.
And she was wearing a pink dress that had little black. And she'd just taken her hat off and had running the.
Through which was now spinning. And she sat there and when I came in she said. Thank you for coming.
She took over immediately and she said. Now here is. Petition.
And I would like to know that fellowship she was already a patron of the fellowship.
And she said I would like the Fellowship would. Approve the petition and circulate it.
And I asked her what the petition was for and she said didn't explain
and it was for the federal government to call a referendum to change the federal Constitution.
And I thought of all of us poverty stricken organisms How do you do it. With a membership of about twenty.
Who's going to change the country was going to change the federal Constitution and I let it.
I put it out of my mind it was too big to comprehend. And she'd already sent that copy.
And he had his and it was pretty crumpled and had.
Plumber's finger marks on it because he'd been showing it around Parliament House where he pointed to supply.
In parliament. It's she thanked me again for coming in. And she said you know I put my money on new meaning.
She'd back me. But that didn't mean much when I went out and hopped in the car and. It was lovely.
I got home and went back to the garden which I'd left that morning I was putting submenu around the place.
Went back and finished off in the afternoon. And I didn't think much more about that petition. I turned it off.
We'll have coffee.